the pores that are in the lighter green
are actively sequencing DNA at the dawn
of the New Millennium the human genome
the DNA code that makes us who we are
was mapped 23 years later that map just
got a lot bigger
[Applause]
the Human Genome Project took more than
a decade to publish its first blueprint
without a doubt this is the most
important most wondrous map ever
produced by humankind
researchers used it as a guide as they
discovered new genes and new potential
cures in our DNA we can be more precise
in how we practice medicine and one way
to get more precise is to have
fundamental blueprint information in
other words genomic information about
each patient that walks into a
healthcare professional's office
but the guide was limited drawn mostly
from one individual It could only
represent the unique traits of their
ancestry now scientists have expanded it
adding samples from nearly 50 people
from populations across the globe it's
now called the pan Genome Project an
example of that actually was a variance
that we uncovered that is primarily
present in East African populations and
it seems to provide strong protection
against malaria infection so if that
variant had been represented in this in
this pan genome resource that would have
simplified our work a great deal I think
the human genome our DNA is three
billion letters long you can see it here
copied and tangled up inside of a
splitting cell's nucleus
more than 99 of it is nearly identical
from person to person
but in that less than one percent There
is almost endless variety all of the
differences that make humans so diverse
and it's that diversity that the pan
genome will begin to map
question now is how to use this new
public information to benefit all of
humanity
I think we're in a remarkable age where
the technology is allowing us to capture
this type of data in high quantities and
across many different regions one of the
keys here at this point will be to
really engage with the communities who
are contributing their genomes to ensure
that it's not just a matter of acquiring
the information without their input but
truly partnering so that the benefits
are equitably shared across all
populations
scientists behind it say they aim to
include 350 more individuals by next
decade to paint a full portrait of our
diverse species Colin Baker Al Jazeera